he wants to fight for the big prize and
here we go the fight has started it's
the king's pawn opening this is what we
saw yesterday between the players as
well a lot of debates in the spanish
that means white light square bishop
developing itself early on this has all
been seen before it's the spanish
opening one of the main lions and
both sides of castle both sides have
developed pieces pawns and now 11
aronian has created a threat he's pushed
upon on this left flank trying to open
up his rook on that a-line so both
players have huge amounts of experience
and vast experience magnus bringing his
bishop out this was also magnus's main
defense the way he played the opening in
2016 against sergey karakin in a world
championship match
ever since that magnus has maybe shied
away from this
opening a bit especially in the biggest
possible games so i decision actually to
slow down because uh magnus has played
this position on a few occasions but uh
this move
is not the most popular one according to
the database and unlikely to have met
be faced by magnus meanwhile the most
popular move has been played actually
so magnus carlsen are following the
trend he wants to get his knight to the
edge of the board to attack the light
squared bishop meanwhile one piece that
has gone off to the right of the
battlefield now is that white bishop and
uh it might look odd to some viewers at
home why that bishop kind of took a
small step one square and then moved
again but i guess the whole plan for
aronian is now that he's locked down
that left side of the board now there's
no more tension with pawns he feels more
free to push his pieces to the other
side will white retreat or will white
trade a piece and okay magnus he doesn't
go for that yet he brings his knight to
the side as uh as we mentioned this is
another very consistent plan the whole
point of the spanish opening is to save
white's light square bishop is to plant
it on a good diagonal so level aronian
retreats that he doesn't want to see a
knight trade off for that bishop white's
light square bishop on the same diagonal
as the black king and now magnus has
switched back to the other idea we
mentioned just combining them in a
different order um he's forcing that the
square bishop this time to declare its
intentions
and yep no trade bishops here they're
quite potent they have decent diagonals
to sit on so no trade for a knight
we've seen magnus take some pauses but
they he took a big pause to play a very
natural move actually to develop just to
over protect his pawn that was under
attack and of course aronia's move is
just to develop his knight and okay so
magnus's plan
was to
play put all his pawns on dark squares
if he's able to explode open the center
okay he plays this which makes a lot of
sense strategically he doesn't bring his
knight in the direction i was saying
that but maybe he was scared of black
opening up the position and if the
center suddenly explodes if all these
pawns start disappearing then the black
bishop will become a good piece then the
black bishop might have a great diagonal
and it does uh but which way is level
rooney going to capture surely with the
bishop okay
yes with the bishop and now the only
issue is for uh for white is that it
takes ages for this knight to get to the
ideal square
and uh actually it takes four moves to
get round now
to this
central outpost and in the meantime
black is maybe gonna get ready to push
in the center for this bishop to come to
life but uh yeah for sure magnus needs
to take action within the next few turns
otherwise he's just gonna suffer
long-term strategically especially
against the might of this bishop
especially white's bind on the light
squares okay both sides just creating
some space for their king right now a
bit of uh
mysterious kind of deep strategy there
i expected level to ronin to okay
first he pushes harry the h4 maybe going
on the attack but at some point he's
going to move this knight out of the way
and try to get it back into the center
you know i have to confess something
david
and
please
those people who love pawn pushers
myself included please forgive me but i
don't really like what the lavon ironian
has done on the right side there i feel
that he's taking a bit too many
liberties with his light squares i think
he's uh completely fine and okay the
knight does drop back and now the bishop
will step forward for sure i expect to
see this one from magnus carson just to
eliminate the white knight any time it
jumps to the center that has happened
and yeah suddenly this night is no
longer such a great piece it's about to
get traded off
and i think it's just level completely
now magnus has definitely solved all his
long-term problems
and okay well we have a threat on the
board and we always get very excited the
queen and bishop were coordinating
together to attack the f7 pawn that's
why magnus quickly defended that pawn
and uh levon now jumping in with his
knight okay so
he had a kind of idea that if bishop
takes knight
then the f line would get open and it
would be maximum pressure
yeah so okay magnus there snacking away
this time this is a pokeball
some kind of beans there yeah no noodles
today noodles today
i've played today he's definitely an
entertainer yeah as well as a sportsman
and uh the night has jumped into the
center it has arrived i know
and david was right you know
magnus was going to say live and let
lift that night i'm going to play around
it and the set takes a step forward with
his king that white knight looks
beautiful but it also blocks the white
bishop temporarily
okay okay and levon out of ideas he just
shuffles his rook across one square
mysterious rick move
i mean is is the queen planning to step
back and push open make way for the pawn
to i think black's the one who wants to
open up the position ivanka i think the
whole reason white played that move is
to bring his other rook into the game i
think white's rook in the corner was
feeling lonely there on the left and the
other rook was in the way so
he's just cleared a square but yes by
the way i'm not a fan and look at the
evaluation bar as well
all the way up in magnus's favor now and
he doesn't hesitate that pawn break that
pawn push that i mentioned trying to
open up the center has been initiated by
magnus and we've seen a couple of trades
suddenly white's lost a lot of stability
in the center eroded the white queen's
stepping back now
and uh yeah there's a lot of
vulnerability around the white king i
mean too many squares and
magnus making a very nice move you know
stepping forward with his bishop
clearing the seventh row for rook
to line up with his partner and then
also i'm thinking the black queen can
even tuck herself in the corner
he moves his rook into the center and
we'll see what magnus is going to choose
later in the game okay magnus ah he
follows your idea i've learned never to
bet against you ivanka
white bishop paralyzed defending it he's
dropped back with his knights right back
okay okay but bishop comes in and now
okay we do have to see the camera yeah
let's go back to the players this is
just winning now for magnus carlsen he's
allowed black's bishop to penetrate and
what's he doing he can't even take this
black rook let's keep an eye on the
players is lev neroni and shaking his
head
yes
he knows his queen was almost trapped he
had to move it using the white knight at
shelter but look magnus is just
merciless pushing poor uh pushing pawns
forward throwing them forward with
abandon attacking this bishop and now if
this bishop moves you know what he's
going to do you might he's just going to
push forward again this knight is pinned
and if the if the rook ever drops off
remember the queen is trapped
this is this is just sensational player
yeah absolutely fantastic model play
from magnus carlsen most times when he's
been on the brink of defeat and he's
kind of
snatched away victory and he did it in
the gold money asian rapid okay so
magnus sorry uh levon retreating the
bishop
yeah magnus does that super accurate
there magnus cast and those mgs accuracy
stats are going through the roof right
now
and yeah black's d pawn is going to
march forward on the next turn and this
pin against white's queen nothing
positive exists anymore okay he pushes
the pawn off on a ronin and there we go
instantly from magnus he pushes his pawn
forward and
now after a trade here in the center
that's not going to change anything
the white knight is simply dropping off
on the next turn
that is
undeniable this white knight is lost
sometimes the answer isn't there and he
can just capture the pawn and the knight
will drop off i i mean there's white
just doesn't have any coordination to
even generate some play against the
exposed black king so the white queen
did get out of the way of the black
bishops but it did come at the cost of
this knight and now magnus he's a whole
bishop up just for one pawn but the
pawns are irrelevant here the black
bishops are extremely strong yeah they
are going to win the game okay we heard
it ding that there it is black's move uh
was just to improve the rook defender
pawn
and
within over the last 10-15 moves it's
not gone in his favor so he definitely
needs to start the next game as quickly
as possible and maintain that rhythm
max rook's doing a decent job okay
magnus retreats his bishop slightly
surprising there so okay and uh now
queen takes rook and again there's no
way to take control of any lines black
queen from the f8 square
has to guard the g8 what else can white
do white's rook as you mentioned ivanka
is stuck defending that e pawn so the
epon does move king nice and safe and
free up the black queen okay
yes
so this is a very nice move now the king
is perfectly safe there in the corner i
think he's uh a mixture of resigning and
losing on time and
okay he did make him work
okay with two seconds left left on a
ronin made that move bringing his rook
across can you just simply go bishop
takes pawn yep he can do anything here
magnus carson he takes a pawn and the
whole idea is actually if white's queen
takes that black bishop you don't
recapture the queen immediately first
the black queen takes the white rook
because the black one is about to drop
it sacrifices itself for a rook and then
you take the white queen and at the end
of that little transition black would be
a whole rook up for nothing yeah only
has to deal against one threat black's
queen slides across
just controlling some light squares as
well there's a huge threat of black
bishops sneaking into the h3 square with
a check to the white king
and okay we see a trade of rooks that
king will hide on a dart square or maybe
black will block this with his bishop i
think he will just block it with a
bishop and
okay aronian really trying to generate
something but it's a mission impossible
that porn
it looks it looks good but it's headed
nowhere and magnus is being ruthless we
have this kind of little motto okay we
have a result levon aronian resigns
wow a great win for magnus carlsen and
the first game of today with the black
pieces as well taking the lead here